Yes, Indiana Jones is among the most beloved
of film franchises, but that doesn't mean
the movies are without their flaws.
We've all rolled our eyes at the scene where
Indy survives a nuclear bomb by hiding in
a refrigerator, but here's a rundown of some
of the other less obvious but still pretty
dumb things that the Indiana Jones movies
ask its viewers to ignore.
When Raiders of the Lost Ark opens, Indiana
Jones is unfazed by his colleague's stories
about ancient, mystical powers that could
destroy everyone seeking the Ark of the Covenant.
By the end of the movie, once he's experienced
a bunch of ghosts with the power to melt Nazis'
faces off, he's forced to accept that there
are powers in the world well beyond his understanding.
He even ends the movie by warning the government
agents that they don't know what they're dealing
with.
"You don't look very happy."
"Fools.
Bureaucratic fools."
"What'd they say?"
"They don't know what they've got there."
Great character arc, right?
Here's the problem: while it came out three
years after Raiders, Temple of Doom is actually
a prequel that takes place a year earlier.
In that movie, Indy saw a man's heart magically
ripped from his chest while still beating
and personally turned magic stones white-hot
by invoking the name of Shiva.
Despite bearing witness to all that, Indiana
Jones is still a skeptic.
In The Last Crusade, he's very quick to dismiss
stories about King Arthur and the Holy Grail
as "bedtime stories."
He's even still hanging onto those doubts
when Crystal Skull rolls around.
It's one thing to try and ensure your character
can be relatable and realistic when he's dealing
with ancient, fantastical mysteries, but for
Indy to simply ignore some of the most exciting,
perplexing, and incredibly real moments of
his life is just silly.
After thrilling chases, a couple of failed
rescue attempts, and outsmarting the bad guys
at every turn throughout Raiders of the Lost
Ark, Indiana Jones and Marion Ravenwood are
captured and forced to witness the hellish
moment when the bad guys open the Ark.
As the power of the Ark is unleashed Indy
tells Marion that they can't look at it, no
matter what happens.
He's right, too: in the midst of a cadre of
Nazis being burned alive by the Wrath of God,
the good guys are spared from its wrath.
So how in the world did Indy know not to look
at the ark?
Earlier in the film, it's mentioned that the
Ark was hidden away due to its immense power
being too much for mankind to handle, but
the cheat code of just closing one's eyes
came kind of out of nowhere.
Also, we're not complaining, but it does seem
a little weird that nobody else figured out
that they shouldn't look at the blinding light
that was melting everyone.
As it turns out, Indy was warned about this
in a scene that was cut from the final version
of the movie.
That might be a good way for Indy to know,
but the audience sure doesn't.
It might seem like we're picking on Raiders,
but in a movie that's otherwise perfect, the
few flaws are really easy to spot.
Take, for instance, Indy's trip on a Nazi
sumbarine.
The key word there is "on", not "in."
With the help of a friendly sea captain, Indy
stealths his way onto a U-Boat to rescue Marion
and defeat Belloq, jumping atop it just before
it goes underwater.
The film then cuts to an island where the
villains plan to open the Ark of the Covenant.
So how did our soaking wet Indy survive the
trip?
Obviously, he couldn't just cling to the periscope
and hold his breath for hundreds of miles,
but from what we see in the movie, and even
a deleted scene, that's exactly what happened.
It's just a good thing nobody ever bothered
to lower the periscope for the entire trip,
or else we'd have to deal with the explanation
that Indy was secretly the lost king of Atlantis
all this time.
When Temple of Doom opens, Indiana Jones is
accompanied by a young child named Wan Li,
who Jones refers to as Short Round.
It's later revealed that the young Chinese
boy from Shanghai got busted trying to pick
the archeologist's pocket and they eventually
became friends.
"You make me poor!
No fun!"
While opinions are split about Short Round,
it's undeniable that he provided some comic
relief, and drove the getaway car, pulled
stunts as daring as his mentor, and even broke
Indy from a magic mind control trance.
By the end of the film, they both return to
the small Indian village as triumphant heroes.
After that...who knows?
The third movie opens with absolutely no mention
of Short Round.
There's not even a whisper of him, nor is
he mentioned in Raiders of the Lost Ark, which
came after Temple of Doom chronologically.
Short Round is just gone after the credits
roll.
Romantic partners like Willie come and go
for a rugged and handsome bachelor like Jones.
The young child that he took under his wing
and brought thousands of miles from his home
on numerous death-defying adventures?
You'd think they'd at least stay in touch.
We might even be willing to forgive some of
Crystal Skull's more egregious sins if Indy's
successor turned out to be Ke Huy Quan instead
of Shia LaBeouf.
There's...a lot to be upset about in Kingdom
of the Crystal Skull, but the most important
might just be that it shifts the genre of
the franchise in a way that just doesn't work.
There's nothing wrong with a good science
fiction story, if that's what you want to
call this movie, but for it to come in the
fourth installment of a franchise rooted in
pulpy, fantastical adventure after a nearly
20-year gap just feels jarring and unnecessary.
"I've got a bad feeling about this."
The movie ends with Jones and his cohorts
finding a collection of alien skeletons with
one missing head.
After returning the infamous crystal skull,
the aliens come to life and vacate Earth in
a flying saucer.
Indiana Jones is a guy who frequently comes
across the unknown in his pursuits of ancient
and mysterious artifacts, but Roswell aliens
are a very different kind of mysterious, even
if, and especially if, they show up 20 years
after he was dealing with Biblical goblets.
They feel out of place in Indy's world of
historical legends and supernatural treasures.
In short, never switch your genre in the fourth
movie of a series.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.